[Music]
welcome to the marketing analytics
Series where we teach practitioners
about Google Cloud marketing analytics
Solutions and showcase their use case
and business value
in video 2 we discuss how to break down
marketing data silos with bigquery
hi I'm Kelsey and for this video we'll
discuss how to democratize marketing
data with bigquery and looker
marketers today face a myriad of
different challenges When developing a
successful marketing data strategy
they face the challenge of Silo data
which is when a collection of data is
held by one group and hard to access by
other groups in an organization
this creates a barrier for information
sharing across an organization and
prevents collaboration
marketers face the challenge of
measuring the return on investment for
their marketing efforts and building
Advanced audience segmentation and
targeting
with the changing privacy landscape it
is becoming more difficult to access
customer data this can make it difficult
for marketers to efficiently bring in
new customers and retain existing ones
marketers also struggle with marketing
Innovation specifically infusing AIML
into marketing Analytics
these three challenges can fail to
provide marketers with the holistic view
of the entire customer Journey which can
lead to poor marketing decisions
a successful marketing data strategy is
critical for addressing these challenges
the four key pillars of a successful
marketing data strategy are data
management which ensures enterprise-wise
collection of governance of first-party
data
data organization which consolidates
data across platforms and matches data
from different systems of holistic View
Advanced analytics which uses techniques
like machine learning to segment users
and predict the next specs action for
marketing teams
activation which operationalizes
customer lists across channels
personalized messaging and does so in a
safe and compliant way these four
pillars allow your various data to be
centralized modeled and democratized if
you are able to achieve these four
pillars with your marketing data this
can lead to better understanding
customer Behavior among different
cohorts of customers the ability to
identify purchasing patterns across
different products or services
finally it makes it easy to analyze the
ROI and impact of your marketing efforts
now that we understand the importance of
effective marketing strategy let's
discuss how Google Cloud tools like
bigquery and looker can be used to build
the strategy bigquery Google Cloud's
fully managed Enterprise data warehouse
allows you to centralize and easily
manage your marketing data one of the
most essential Google Cloud tools that
can help build your marketing strategies
looker looker is a platform that can
help your business to quickly analyze
and find insights in your data sets
looker makes it easy to build a data
exploration platform that democratizes
data and operationalizes insights across
your organization looker also allows you
to model all of your customer data
together this eliminates data silos and
provides a centralized government access
to high-level dashboards self-service
data exploration looker has native and
custom activation points to build custom
audiences around Google marketing
platform and other data sources like CRM
and activate those audiences across
marketing channels
now let's bring this information
together with a quick demo
in this demo I'll show you how using
looker helps you put your first party
data to work with pre-built blocks and
Native actions
let's start first with looker blocks
looker blocks are pre-built installable
code for common analytical patterns and
data sources they allow you to reuse the
work of others and make the necessary
customization so you can get up and
running quickly
and there you have it in this video we
learned the importance of data driven
marketing data strategy the four pillars
building a marketing data strategy and
finally how you can use looker block and
looker action to help your company
achieve a successful marketing data
strategy if you enjoyed this video
please make sure to like this video and
click the Subscribe button to watch more
videos like this
foreign
[Music]